President Trump says the derailment
shows the need to invest in
infrastructure he tweeted seven trillion
dollars spent in the Middle East while
our roads bridges tunnels raw railways
and more crumble not for long but the
tracks where the accident happened
actually were brand new and some critics
warned that high-speed travel there
could be dangerous Carter Evans is in
nearby Lakewood Washington where local
officials raised concerns Carter good
morning good morning
Amtrak 501 pass through here just
minutes before derailing about nine
miles down the track now lake woods
mayor had argued that recent track
upgrades were not sufficient and he was
worried about collisions at crossings
like this one we always felt that the
reward wasn't big enough to take on the
risk lakewood mayor Don Anderson feared
for years that Amtrak's new high-speed
cascades route would lead to disaster
Public Safety is that was our primary
concern with this line coming through
it's people being on the tracks and
trains coming off the tracks in a highly
urbanized area at a city council meeting
earlier this month he urged State
Transportation officials to improve
safety along the line
the nearly 15 mile bypass where Monday's
crash occurred was designed to save time
avoiding curves and traffic on the old
route and allowing trains to reach
speeds of nearly 80 miles per hour
Amtrak says automatic braking technology
known as positive train control or PTC
was not activated on the tracks at the
time of the derailment federal
investigators have found PTC could have
prevented rail accidents including a
2015 Amtrak derailment in Philadelphia
that killed eight Deborah Hersman is a
former chairperson for the NTSB
nationwide we need positive train
control on all passenger routes this
technology is within reach and it's
because of the dollars that need to be
spent
that's delayed its implementation now
Amtrak began installing positive train
control back in 2000 and plans to be
compliant with federal laws requiring
all railroads to have it by 2021 Amtrak
officials also say they did upgrade
several crossings and work to inform the
public about the new train tracks Gale
all right thank you very much Carter
Evans